sehr geehrte staats und regierungschefs
meine damen und herren dieser 70
jahrestag der gründung der vereinten
nationen ist eine gute gelegenheit über
die geschichte zu sprechen und über
unsere gemeinsame zukunft zu reden
1945 waren die länder die den nazismus
besiegt haben so aufgestellt dass ihre
fertig zusammengelegt haben ihm eine
neue weltordnung aufzubauen aber die
schlüssel entscheidung über die
grundlagen der zusammenarbeit zwischen
staaten und grundlagen der die
einrichtung der vereinten nationen
wurden in unserem land gelegt
auf der konferenz von jalta als sich die
führer der anti hitler koalition dort
getroffen haben das system von jalta
millionen von menschenleben durchgesetzt
und das war diese geschichte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts lassen sie uns
der menschheit geholfen durch turbulente
zeiten
politische ereignisse max nach 70 jahren
das alte system hat enthält bewahrt vor
gross nun wird zerstört vereinten
nationen sind einzigartig mira
legitimität in ihrer repräsentativität
und dass sie nicht effizient genug
handeln werden und auch wegen der
tatsache dass die entscheidungsfindung
zur wichtigen themen oft wegen
unüberwindbarer differenzen zwischen des
sicherheitsrates sich fest frist und
nicht weiterkommt
aber obwohl es immer wieder
meinungsverschiedenheiten gab in den 70
jahren der existenz wurde das vetorecht
immer wieder auch von den usa eingesetzt
vom feinsten königreich von frankreich
von china von der sowjetunion und später
russland
es ist absolut natürlich für so
unterschiedliche vertreter von ländern
dass das geschieht als die un
eingerichtet wurden haben die
gründungsväter nicht geglaubt dass es
immer einstimmigkeit geben würde
die mission von organisationen besteht
darin kompromisse zu suchen und zu
erziehen und die stärke kommt daraus
verschiedene standpunkte dabei zu
berücksichtigen
entscheidungen hat der un diskutiert
wurden werden um entweder als
resolutionen dann gefällt oder nicht als
diplomaten wissen wir dass resolutionen
verabschiedet werden oder auch nicht
welche maßnahmen auch immer ein staat
ergreift
außer dieser prozeduren sind illegitim
weil sie dem völkerrecht widersprechen
und der un charta widersprechen wir
wissen alle dass nach dem ende des
kalten krieges und es lässt sich jeder
bewusst 1 1 ein einziges herrschaft
zentrum in der welt entstanden ist und
die ihm die sich an der spitze der
pyramide wiederfinden versucht sind zu
glauben dass sie so stark sind und so
außergewöhnlich sein dass sie es besser
wissen als andere und einigte sich mit
der un verständigen müssen
die das sozusagen automatisch
autorisiert und legitimiert werden ihre
entscheidungen durchzusetzen
aber dem steht die un entgegen
das wurde jetzt sozusagen es wurde jetzt
häufig gesagt dass die un in ihrer
jetzigen form obsolet geworden sein weil
die historische mission erfüllt sei
natürlich verändert sich die welt und
die un müssen diesem wandlungsprozess
auch folgen und ihm entsprechen russland
ist bereit mit seinen partnern auf
grundlage des konsenses
zusammenzuarbeiten und lager eines
breiten konsenses aber
die versuche die legitimität der nation
zu untergraben betrachten wir als extrem
gefährlich
sie können zum zusammenbruch der
gesamten architektur der in terrassa
beziehung führen und dann blieben keine
anderen regeln mehr übrig als das gesetz
des stärkeren
wir hätten dann eine welt die von
egoismus statt gemeinsamer arbeit
bestimmt wäre einer welt die vom diktat
bestimmt würde statt von gleichheit
zwischen der jacksons
es geht dann weniger demokratie und
freiheit dies für eine welt in der
unabhängige staaten ersetzt würden durch
eine wachsende zahl von de facto
protektorat die von außen kontrolliert
berlin
was ist denn übrig geblieben sonst von
der staatlichen souveränität das geht
doch um den begriff der freiheit und das
recht die eigene zukunft zu gestalten
und ein recht das jedem menschen jede
nation ihrer stadt hat liebe kollegen
dasselbe gilt für die frage der
sogenannten legitimität der staatlichen
autorität der staatlichen macht man
sollte mit worten nicht spielen oder sie
auch nicht manipulieren jeder begriff
dem völkerrecht und in sozialen
angelegenheiten sollte klar transparent
und deutlich in seiner bedeutung sein
und eine gemeinsam verständliche
bedeutung tragen wir sind ja alle
unterschiedlich und wir sollten das auch
respektieren aneinander niemand muss
einem einzigen entwicklungsmodell folgen
dass irgendjemand anders als das einzig
gültige aufgestellt hat wir sollten uns
alle daran erinnern was unsere
vergangenheit uns gelehrt hat wir
sollten uns auf ein bestimmtes episoden
der geschichte erinnern da der
geschichte der sowjetunion soziale
experimente die man exportieren will um
veränderungen andern ländern
herbeizuführen aufgrund ideologischer
präferenzen führen häufig zu tragischen
konsequenzen und zerfall stadt zu
fortschritt es scheint jedoch so zu sein
dass das lernen dass das stadt von den
fehlern anderer zu lernen jeder die
fehler wiederholt so ist also der export
von revolution
jetzt unter dem deckmantel des export
von demokratien ein versuch der zum
scheitern verurteilt ist in meinem
vorredner hat alice dazu erwähnt hatte
erklärt dass soziale probleme in afrika
zum beispiel seit langem sich aufstauen
und die menschen dort veränderungen
wünschen natürlich aber was ist denn
geschehen was war das ergebnis statt
reformen zu erzielen
die einmischung von außen dazu geführt
dass nationale institutionen und der
lebens stehendes ländern zerstört und
statt des triumphes von demokratie und
fortschritt erleben wir gewalt armut und
soziale katastrophen und niemand schert
sie im mindesten um menschenrechte
inklusive das recht auf leben
ich frage die ihnen die das verursacht
haben wird euch jetzt klar was ihr
angerichtet habt aber ich befürchte
jemand wird darauf antworten politik
beruht ihre politik beruht auf dem
glauben dass sie selber eine
außergewöhnliche rolle spielen eine
sonderrolle die und straflos alles tun
können
es ist jetzt doch offensichtlich
geworden dass das was im nahen osten und
in afrika nordafrika geschehen ist zum
anarchie geflirtet und zu allen eine
heimstatt für terroristen und
extremisten
zehntausende von kämpfern stehen jetzt
unter der flagge des sogenannten
islamischen staates
dazu gehören ehemalige irakische
soldaten die auf die straße geworfen
wurden nach dem einmarsch im irak 2003
viele rekruten kommen auch aus libyen
einem land dessen staatliche ordnung
zerschlagen wurde auf grundlage einer
grill einer koalition die eine sichere
weg sind so wollte angeblich und simmern
hat man hat erst die sogenannten
moderator opposition bewaffnet und
ausgebildet und dann sind die
übergelaufen zum islamischen staat
der islamische staat selbst kam jedoch
nicht aus dem nichts
er wurde auch ursprünglich als gruppe
aufgebaut ging ungewünschte säkuläre
regimes hat man daran gedacht im irak
und syrien
dort ist der islamische staat entstanden
und sucht dringend jetzt in andere
regionen vor und sucht die vorherrschaft
in der islamischen welt zu erringen und
die pläne gehen darüber hinaus die
situation ist in mehr als gefährlich
unter diesen umständen ist es reine
heuchelei jetzt über die bedrohung des
interessant terrorismus zu reden während
man gleichzeitig ein augen verschließt
vor den kanälen der finanzierung dieses
netzwerks von terroristen entschied auch
durch drogenschmuggel durch
waffenschmuggel und so weiter es ist
verantwortungslos
die extremistischen gruppen in den
eigenen dienst zu stellen um politische
ziele zu erreichen in der hoffnung
später schon mit denen fertig zu werden
oder in anderen worten zu liquidieren
denen die dieses tun möchte ich sagen
meine herren
zweifellos haben sie mit dort mit ganz
brutalen bösartigen menschen zu tun aber
sie sind dich primitiv oder dumm sie
folgen einfach ihrem beispiel
und die frage ist welche will
manipuliert und zb gibt es ja doch die
die beweise dass die waffen die an die
sogenannte moderate opposition geliefert
wurden in handys gelandet sind
also diese versuche sie zu bewaffnen
ist doch sind doch gescheitert das führt
dazu dass die bedrohung durch den
terrorismus wächst und neue regionen
er greift sondern wenn man sich anschaut
dass in dem ausbildungslager des
islamischen staates kämpfer aus allen
ländern jetzt inklusive der europäischen
länder und meine freunde das ist sie
keine ausnahme was wir können nicht
zulassen dass diese kriminalität schon
blut gespuckt haben
nun jetzt nach hause kommen um dort ihre
übeltaten niemand will dass das geschäft
oder russland hat immer gegen den
terrorismus bekämpfen als ein von heute
liefern wir militärische und technische
hilfe für irak durch während für andere
länder
die terroristischen gruppen bekämpfen
das wäre ein enormer fehler die
zusammenarbeit mit der syrischen
regierung und ihren streitkräften zu
verweigern
während sie den wie terrorismus von
angesicht zu angesicht bekämpfen niemand
anders als präsident assad und seine
streitkräfte und milizen kämpfen gegen
den islamischen staates und anderer
touristischer zu und syrien wir wissen
dass es all diese probleme und konflikte
in der region gibt ich muss feststellen
dass eine solcher ehrlicher und offener
ansatz von den russland gewählt hat nun
genutzt wird als vorwand russland
ambitionen zu unterstellen die über das
eigene land hinaus gehen es geht hier
aber nicht um russlands ambitionen
sondern um die anerkennen wird seine
kollegen dass wir nicht länger den
aktuellen zustand der welt tolerieren
können sondern wir müssen uns leiten
lassen von gemeinsamen werten und
gemeinsam interessen statt von
ambitionen 12 nationen auf grundlage des
völkerrechts müssen wir unsere
anstrengungen zusammenlegen die probleme
zu bekämpfen
die nunmehr alle heute beherrschen und
die müssen brauchen eine breite
internationale ein breites bündnis gegen
den terrorismus sowie die anti hitler
koalition könnte dies ein bündnis im
breites bündnis von kräften herstellen
die entschlossen sind die ihnen zu
bekämpfen die genau wie die nazis von
hass gegen die menschheit erfüllt sind
und dabei müssen auch die islamischen
länder eine schlüsselrolle spielen
noch mehr so weil der islamische staat
nicht nur einen dreck übertrumpfte
wieder erstellt sondern erst recht weil
der islamische staat einer der
wichtigsten religion der welt
diskreditiert
sie datieren die humanistischen werte
des islam ich möchte die auf die
spirituellen lieder des der moslems
ansprechen
ihre autorität und ihre führungsrolle
ist jetzt besonders wichtig es ist
wichtig menschen daran zu erinnern dass
sie sich von extremisten rekrutieren
lassen und die in die bereits enttäuscht
wurden und die aufgrund der umstände
sich jetzt in den reihen der terroristen
wiederfinden den muss man helfen den weg
in ein normales leben zurückzufinden und
die waffen niederzulegen russland wird
in kürze ein minister treffen einberufen
wenn wir die präsidentschaft im
sicherheitsrat übernehmen ein
ministertreffen zur beratung der
strategien gegen die bedrohungen im
nahen osten wir wollen eine resolution
verabschieden zur koordinierung aller
kräfte die den islamischen staat und am
touristischen organisationen kämpfen
einmal mehr diese koordinierung sollte
beruhen auf den grundsätzen der
un-charta wir hoffen dass die
internationale gemeinschaft in der lage
sein wird eine umfassende strategie
politischer stabilisierung zu entwickeln
um den auch die soziale und
wirtschaftliche erholung und der
aufschwung im nahen osten zu fördern
dann wird es keine werden keine neuen
flüchtlingscamps notwendig werden denn
diese welle der flüchtlinge hat ja
zunächst die nachbarländer und jetzt
europa überschwemmen hunderttausend
vielleicht noch millionen die kommen das
ist eine neue große und tragische
völkerwanderung und eine harte lektion
für uns alle einschließlich europa ich
möchte jeder mal betonen dass
flüchtlinge zweifellos unser
mitgeführten unterstützung benötigen
aber das problem auf grundlage
ebene anzugehen erfordert ja stabilität
in den heimatländern dieser flüchtlinge
herzustellen damit sie dort wieder
chancen haben auf dieses leben das
bedeutet umfassende hilfe
wirtschaftlicher und militärischer art
für die länder in dieser schwierigen
lage und insbesondere hilfe für die
menschen die trotz aller aller notlagen
ihr heimatland nicht aufgeben
hilfe für souveräne staaten muss
angeboten werden statt aufgezwungen
einschließlich der maßnahmen in
übereinstimmung mit der ente alles was
getan wird nach maßgabe der regel des
völkerrechts muss unterstützt werden
unsere organisation alles was der
un-charta widerspricht muss abgelegt
werden glaube ich das ist
außerordentlich wichtig ist jetzt auch
die entsprechenden regierungsstrukturen
wiederherzustellen in libyen im irak und
jetzt auch von der legitimen regierung
in syrien die hilfe nicht zu verweigern
meine eben kollegen indem wir den
frieden und für weltweite stabilität
gewährleisten
führen wir den die aufgabe der vereinten
nationen aus und sorgen für
gerechtigkeit dies nicht nur für einige
wenige auf dieser welt gibt sondern die
aufgabe ist für alle anderen wird dazu
gibt es keine alternative
er könne nicht mehr in den kriterien des
kalten krieges zu denken und die bei
manchen ist das aber sitzt zwar immer
noch in den köpfen sie verfolgen immer
noch ihrer politik der ausweitung des
einflusses einfluss wäre der nato
beispielsweise und die denken die
sowjetunion zerfallen die nato versucht
also sich weiterhin als militärische
infrastruktur auszubreiten und deshalb
stellen sie uns vor eine falsche wahl
früher oder später wird diese logik der
konfrontation in einer politischen krise
enden das ist ja genau das was in der
ukraine geschehen ist und geschichte des
die die bevölkerung wurde missbraucht
und die mir das militär in der
er wurde missbraucht um hier und das hat
man davon nämlich einen bürgerkrieg in
der ukraine nur durch die völlige um
fällige umsetzung des minsker abkommens
können wir ein blutvergiessen ein ende
setzen es sehen sie die territoriale
unversehrtheit kann nur so erreicht
werden es wird muss wir müssen im
interesse natürlich auch der menschen in
der donbass region
wir müssen die kernelemente der politik
des landes als einen zivilisierten staat
auch berücksichtigen wie wir für einen
mit einer starken wirtschaftlichen
sozialen struktur in europa und meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich habe
diesen bereich der möglichkeiten der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
natürlich extra hier auch erwähnt wir
wollen wir wollen leben ohne grenzlinien
ohne trennlinien die uns voneinander
ausschlüssen wir wollen die grundsätze
der welthandelsorganisation also der
hand freiheit des handelns offene
handeln also weiter auch umgesetzt sehen
wir sehen sie unilaterale also
einseitige sanktionen werden ja immer
öfter erlassen und verfügt aufgrund
eines vermeintlichen politischen
fehlverhaltens gegen den politischen
wettbewerber aber auch das ist nur
ausdruck des wirtschaftlichen egoismus
weltweit hinter das hinter den hinter
den kulissen wird verhandelt und es wird
es werden die interessen einzelner
staaten verfolgt wo mit den interessen
anderer staaten geschadet wird wir
werden hier vor den fernblick gesetzt
dass hier offensichtlich die
internationalen beziehungen
zugunsten einer kleinen gruppe von
ländern hier verändert wurden und es
nicht zum globalen wirtschaftlichen
frieden bei das wird selbstverständlich
auch die zukunft der weltwirtschaft in
zukunft beeinflussen wir wollen das
jetzt also auch diskutieren im kreise
der g 20 und der welthandelsorganisation
geschlagen vor dass wir wird regional
gebundene wirtschaftliche projekte
harmonisieren dass wir sie integrieren
auf der grundlage von universalen
ehernen gesetzen des internationalen
handels wir wollen eurasien
wirtschaftlich vernetzen mitglieder vor
allen dingen auch wirtschaftlich uns
austauschen wir glauben immer noch daran
dass die harmonisierung des
integrationsprozesses in der
europäischen union und in eurasien sehr
wichtige prozesse sind meine damen und
herren die themen die die zukunft
insbesondere auch bei beeinflussende
wieder klimawandel da ist liegt es in
unserem interesse dass wir an der dass
wir dafür sorgen auch mit dafür sorgen
dass die kopp 21 klimakonferenz in paris
ein erfolg wird
indem nämlich bis 2030 die co2
emissionen 50 bis 70 prozent des levels
von 1990 reduziert werden
wir können natürlich wenn wir quoten
festsetzen
das problem noch ein wenig weiter
vertagen das sind rein technische
diskussionen weil wir damit das problem
der klimaerwärmung nicht lösen wir
brauchen einen völlig neuen ansatz wir
müssen uns konzentrieren auf die
einführung neuer technologien
umweltfreundlicher technologien die aus
uns zugleich ermöglichen hier auch für
eine ausgewogene entwicklung zwischen
umwelt interessen und wirtschaftlichen
interessen zu sorgen
der mensch hat die menschheit hat die
intellektuelle kapazität in dieser
probleme zu lesen und lösen und wir
müssen und deshalb unsere
alle bündeln müssen dass auf der
grundlage einer soliden forschung tun
wir schlagen deshalb auch vor dass wir
ein spezielles forum unter dem unter der
ägide der uno einberufen
dass dann auch die ressourcen der
einzelnen länder bündeln und verwalten
könnte für den kampf gegen den
klimawandel meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren liebe kollegen in einer im
september 146 hat sich die uno
vollversammlung zum ersten mal
zusammengesetzt
ein kolumbianischer diplomat eröffnete
seinerzeit die sitzung und gab eine
klare definition der grundsätze der
zukünftigen zusammenarbeit der uno er
sagte heute und das sind die worte
dienen uns als führung
wir glauben an das große potenzial der
vereinten nationen mit dem wir eine
weitere globale konfrontation verhindern
können und strategisch miteinander
zusammenarbeiten können mit allen
ländern damit wir ihr auch die damit ja
auch die uno-staaten die aktivitäten der
staaten miteinander koordinieren muss
damit die welt ein sicherer und stabiler
dort wird in dem die menschen in frieden
zusammenleben herzlichen dank